hi there my name is Tamsin Taylor I work
in the Google Play apps and games
partnerships team in a mere I've been
working to monetize mobile content with
partners since 2001 and I can tell you
that play is a global marketplace
platform for distributing software
transactions are vital to any
marketplace so we take our platforms
incredibly seriously our whole job is to
enable developers like you to build and
run global businesses and we're
extremely proud of what we've achieved
but we're still working incredibly hard
to continue delivering business and
spend to you now monetization is driven
by a number of best practices including
quality design and investment in using
the great features that the Android
platform offers such as alpha beta
testing stage rollouts and cloud test
lab you should also consider strategies
to drive engagement increase retention
and grow user lifetime value and of
course consider using analytics to
really know who your users are and be
able to create optimal experiences for
them but in the next 20 minutes I'm
going to talk to you about how you can
increase monetization using pricing best
practices and some of the tools that we
have at your disposal so you can succeed
there's big money should be made on
Google Play in fact we paid out seven
billion dollars to our developers last
year when you operate on Play you have
access to over a billion users and
hundreds of millions of buyers we've had
huge teams spend years building gigantic
reach into our commerce platform in more
countries with more ways for users to
pay and in fact we see a lift in
incremental sales and new customers
whenever we introduce a new form of
payment so the faster we unlock new
forms of payment the larger the pool of
users who can purchase your app we now
support over 100 forms of payment across
152 countries and we're constantly
working on new payment partnerships
building more ways for your users to pay
you and offering locally irrelevant
payment methods to convert more users
for example we recently unlocked direct
carrier billing in India we are
committed to make it easier and easier
for your users to pay you and we're
seeing it pay off so in Germany for
example we saw a 70 percent increase on
year-on-year buyer growth
and more and more developers are selling
outside the home market we saw a 38
percent annual growth in developers with
primarily international sales
so given this increasingly global market
how should you price your top quality
application there are five key points to
setting and managing your prices
effectively matching the model to the
market considering purchasing power
considering price format preferences
taking into account audience
segmentation and regularly checking your
prices top developers consider the
pricing model for keen markets and
cultural expectations for example some
prepaid markets have low credit card
penetration and are less predictable in
which cases models like free premium or
in-app purchase might be more relevant
for them and if considering a
subscription model your value
proposition should give users a regular
fresh ongoing content or functionality
consider what people can afford last
year in November we lowered the minimum
price in India from fifty to ten rupees
now consider a can of coke cost 10
rupees in India roughly whereas in the
u.s. it's a dollar and the exchange rate
stays 66 rupees to the dollar so you can
see there's a big difference in how much
people are charged and their purchasing
power parity so it's important to give
the right consumer the right price now
for weeks after we launched this change
in the pricing we saw take up from 560
titles across 220 developers after this
four-week period we saw an 800 percent
increase in revenue and interestingly
three-quarters of the developers frog
were from outside India this really
highlights the growth in
internationalization of our ecosystem
one of our partners Nova dropped their
price from 325 rupees to 15 rupees and
saw a big impact they saw 136 percent
increase in orders and 27 percent
increase in revenue now the best way to
find out what purchasing parity
differences there are across countries
is to look at Big Mac index which you
can find on the Economist website
many top partners are testing prices in
overseas markets learning language at
boo Sood tested ABCD price tests across
Russia in the u.s. to find the optimal
price for those different consumers in
the USA it ended up being a 23%
reduction which resulted in 95 percent
increase in conversion and 52 percent
increase in our poo in Russia it was
different the optimal price was 12
percent lower which resulted in 15%
increase in conversion and 17 percent
increase in our poo so the caveat here
is don't take our word fruit test
yourselves test your different prices to
find the optimal point for increased
conversion and incremental revenue in
your different markets consider local
price preferences and optimize the price
format for different markets for example
in Korea and Japan they prefer pricing
which is ends in whole rounded numbers
such as one thousand two thousand etc
whereas in Australia we prefer $1.99
$2.99 now you can do this in the
developer console in fact you can
customize a price for every single
market and we'll take care of billing
the users in their local currency we
think you've used this an optimized
price and a value offering that works
for them they're more likely to agree to
purchase or subscribe to your offer now
users are not homogeneous and it's best
practice to know who they are
their appetite to pay and carve out
different strategies to help them on
their purchase journey and we provide
the tools to help you there's great
reporting in developed developer console
and Google Analytics gives you the
ability to identify and target different
offers to different segments also help
you increase conversion and ARPU you
really should use analytics to better
understand your audience engagement
using KPIs like last visit loyalty
and average tenure to really help you
improve purchase flows develop user
segments based on predictive lifetime
value and start targeting different
segments with optimal offers wish did
this and so our 10% uplift from
presenting different offers to highly
engaged versus less engaged user
segments
finally developers should regularly
review and adjust prices primarily for
two reasons
number one to ensure you're still
competitive with similar apps and
secondly in response to changes in
foreign exchange for example a developer
who set their price in February 2014 and
didn't change it for a year would have
seen in February 15 that their growth
revenue from Russia had dropped nearly
50 percent severely impacting margin
just from an exchange rate movement so
to recap the five best practices I've
mentioned so far
they were matching the model to the
market considering purchasing power
consider user price format preferences
use audience segmentation and regularly
check your prices now a running theme
here is that not all users are the same
they have different price sensitivities
so how can you deal with this and
increase monetization I'll now touch on
how you can use AdMob to monetize across
different types of users and then I'll
talk to the power of subscriptions
before wrapping up AdMob is our
industry-leading ads and mediation
platform that's earned over 650,000
developers over 1 billion dollars in the
last 2 years the growth statistics are
impressive this tells us that not only
does AdMob work well but it tells us
something about the ecosystem
advertising is a significant part of
that monetization and is growing every
year
in fact gartner predicts that by 2017
there will be nearly 270 billion apps
downloaded majority being free or
freemium now with this growth in free
and freemium apps comes growth in mobile
advertising now I mentioned earlier the
consumer is different between markets
because of income or cultural
preferences and a monetization strategy
may work in one market but not in
another we believe that a developer
shouldn't be forced to choose between
advertising or in-app purchase only in
fact the best apps focus on users first
and you should be able to build
monetization around the user AdMob can
help you find the right monetization
opportunity because it has a smart
monetization engine and this is a
feature called
in-app purchase ads
it helps promote in-app purchase items
to users so you can grow your in-app
purchase revenue by automatically
knowing which users are buyers
and which are less likely to spend it
looks at spend behavior in your app and
only shows ads to those less likely to
buy freeing up valuable impressions for
you plus it's integrated with Google
Analytics in-app purchase and ads are
two great ways to make money and with
AdMob you can automate the presentation
of the offer to match the users likely
spend behavior another model which works
well for generating recurring revenue is
subscriptions
users and developers love subscriptions
they've become widely accepted and
adopted across a music movie and TV
industries and this adoption is being
seen in apps for users subscriptions
mean no unforeseen chargeable events
they remove the fear and increase trust
the app is always there for you when you
need it for developers subscriptions
mean recurring revenue which is great
for cash flow and did you know that
subscriptions are the fastest growing
business model on play last year they
showed two and a half times growth year
on year but why is this first of all
users are getting used to paying for
digital content and secondly the overall
standard of quality in Android apps is
increasing leaps and bounds led by
industry leading developers like
yourselves and many developers are
seeing success busuu redesigned our
onboarding flows and app design to
better communicate their new
subscription value propositions after
optimizing their subscription offers
they found their Android retention beat
all other platforms and their
subscription revenue increased one
hundred and twenty five percent and the
ARPU increased 86% the New York Times
implemented Google Play billing
replacing their traditional news
publisher pay wall this resulted in
users signup flow shortening from two
minutes to three seconds and a one
hundred and twenty five percent increase
in subscription conversion after the
first month and two hundred and fifty
four percent increase year on you
Pandora also saw a three hundred ninety
seven percent revenue increase through
optimizing their conversions by offering
a trial period it's really important
with subscription model to allow users
to try before they buy
you can decide the lengths yourself but
show them the value to increase
likelihood of converting Google offers
heaps of functionality to build a
successful subscriptions business there
are upgrades and downgrades to help ease
a barrier of entry by offering multiple
plans to users there are grace periods
for helping people when their payments
declined and there are goodwill credits
which can be used for promotion or
complaints and of course it's all
supported by deep financial metrics
available in the developer console and
last year we even added additional time
periods which now enable you to really
create interesting compelling off it's
based on weekly monthly quarterly six
monthly and annual recurring billing
periods Google Play is a huge growing
market and pricing is one lever for
better monetization but it must be
executed in combination with
improvements in quality and by having a
deep knowledge about your users you can
achieve success by following the five
pricing best practices I mentioned today
be flexible about your monetization
model consider using AdMob to reach
non-paying users and utilize the new
range of subscription models to grow
your revenue annuity thanks for watching
you